chemistry
it is the study of what
anyone
chemistry is
well technically
chemistry is the study of matter
but I prefer to see it as the study of
change
well that's that's all of life right I
mean it's just it's the constant it's
the cycle it's it is growth then Decay
then transformation
it is fascinating really
I've always had a soft spot for TB but
accepted it for what it was if that
makes sense it was a distraction
something you did when you didn't have
anything else to do and there were a lot
of shows that were great for that there
was never a sense that you were
witnessing High art or that you needed
to tune in to watch every single episode
of your favorite show I didn't expect
much other than to be distracted and
hopefully entertained I wanted to sit
down in front of it have the moving
pictures work their magic and take me
out of my head for the next 30 minutes
to an hour I grew up with it I often
found myself sucked into it but could
also take it or leave it then Breaking
Bad sort of snuck up on me at a time
where I was looking for something to get
into and ever since then I've
consistently been watching something it
changed the way I interacted with TV and
well here we are everyone knows what
breaking bad is Even if they haven't
seen it the cultural influence it has
now makes it hard to believe that not
that many people were watching the first
couple see reasons as they aired other
than Bryan Cranston winning Emmys there
wasn't that much Buzz about it I
discovered it got caught up and was
invested by the Time season 3 came out
and was really surprised to find people
at work who had watched the season 4
premiere after it became available on
Netflix its profile hit New Heights and
that was the first show I remember that
happening to and by the time season five
was on everyone was watching and had an
opinion on how it might end so what
about you how did you get into Breaking
Bad I was one of those Netflix
latecomers many of my friends and
colleagues were raving about it and when
it hit Netflix I decided to check it out
and got sucked into my first ever binge
watching experience I didn't move from
the couch for what felt like weeks I'm
exaggerating of course though not by
much around 1 or 2 A.M each night my
partner was like we have to go to bed
and after the show ended we watched it
again almost immediately I got to be
with Better Call Saul from the the
beginning and it has been interesting to
reflect on how different the experiences
have been not just because they're
different shows but the difference in
the viewing experience binge watching
versus having to wait a week in between
episodes or months in between seasons
and as was the case with the final
season of Saul years and with the
conclusion of Better Call Saul in August
of 2022 we now have more answers and
deeper insights into the world and
characters Breaking Bad informs much of
how I viewed Better Call Saul and El
Camino and not that anyone needs an
excuse to re-watch what is arguably one
of the best shows ever made but I look
forward to watching Breaking Bad again
now that we have a full Universe of
characters and stories to
recontextualize it it was the right show
at the right time and it influences so
much of what we see on TV today it
didn't really reinvent the wheel as much
as it played to the strengths that
already existed in the medium and made
what I think was a very very smart
choice to focus on the main character's
transformation over the entire series
rather than being a show that kept one
foot in the episodic format such as
wildly popular ones like the X-Files
which is where Creator Vince Gilligan
got his start I'm Pete and I'm joined by
my non-acidic co-host Courtney hello and
we're here today to introduce you to our
new podcast growth Decay transformation
a Breaking Bad re-watch podcast
why does this need to exist and why are
we doing this right now the 15th
anniversary of the pilot just passed and
that feels like enough time to go back
and revisit the series and have a new
experience and when you dig into the
history of how it came into existence
there are so many interesting
occurrences where if things had just
broken a different way this might have
been a completely different show one of
my favorite Vince Gilligan quotes is
about how coincidences are lazy writing
unless they are bad for the characters
but everything aligns perfectly for the
show to be created how and when it was
from the timing to the writer's strike
to the rise of Netflix and it's Legacy
is something I imagine we will be
talking about for a long time and
something I look forward to exploring
more on this podcast it was fortuitous
that we were both on YouTube talking
about Better Call Saul at the same time
and got to meet because of our shared
love for this world
and for those of you who don't know us
I'm Pete peppers I have a YouTube
channel of the same name where I make TV
related videos those are mostly weekly
episode Recaps for current shows as they
air I've been doing that for a while and
I'll continue to do that because it's
something I like to do but I've also
wanted to dig a Little Deeper have
conversations about some of these shows
I probably wouldn't be doing any of this
if I hadn't come across Breaking Bad
when I did and it didn't have such a
huge impact on my hot and cold love
affair with TB
and I'm Courtney I also have a YouTube
channel Courtney's reviews that I
created to discuss Better Call Saul I
love shows like Breaking Bad and Better
Call Saul because not only are they fun
to watch but they have huge payoffs and
reward viewers for investing their time
I missed out on getting to discuss every
episode of Breaking Bad when it first
aired analyzing every little aspect of
it around the water cooler trying to
guess what would happen next but I did
get to do that with Saul and that was a
very engaging and in my case social
experience I very much look forward to
revisiting Breaking Bad Now And
discussing each episode with up and all
of you listeners out there it's one of
those shows that like any great film or
book deserves to be talked about and
Revisited and that's why we've decided
to start this podcast this will be a
full Spoilers Podcast meaning it won't
be for first-time viewers Aeron and Jim
have a complete Breaking Bad podcast
called breaking good on this network
that you can check out if you're
watching for the first time there will
also be spoil Oilers for everything in
the Breaking Bad universe so if you
haven't seen Better Call Saul or El
Camino you should go watch those before
listening we will be discussing each
episode in order but as this is a
retrospective re-watch we will likely
discuss things that happen in later
episodes and in Better Call Saul and El
Camino like Chuck McGill's copy of the
time machine sitting on Jimmy's bedside
table this is your warning that our
conversations will at times be
non-linear and travel back and forth
across time in the Breaking Bad universe
we invite you to join us as we retrace
the growth Decay and transformation in
Breaking Bad this will not only be a
nostalgic look back and rediscovery of
what made it so great but discovery of
new things that continue to make it
relevant today
you're a goddamn artist
this this is Arts Mr White
actually it's just basic chemistry but
thank you Jesse I'm glad it's acceptable
acceptable you're the Goddamn Iron Chef
every jib head from here to Timbuktu is
going to want to taste
where can potential listeners find us
you can contact us at breaking badgdt
gmail.com that's gdt as in growth Decay
transformation and you can follow us on
Twitter at Breaking Bad gdt for updates
you can find our podcast growth Decay
transformation on baldmove.com or
anywhere you find your favorite podcasts